blue baba tv
welcome again and this is baba tv a
channel that will feature different
things concerning agriculture and
farming
and today is another session in which we
have another topic
to speak about most of people will be
surprised because we have just used
english but we have just done this for
intention because
we have the other is that we have a lot
of fans from different areas
who are living apart from tanzania so
in order for them to catch up with us we
decided
in each week we should have one session
which will be speaking english
so as to enable people from different
areas to catch up with
us so our fans from kenya south africa
canada
u.s and whatever this is for you and if
you have noted considering subscribing
do it and hit the bell so as to be
updated and informed every time when we
put new updates in your channel
how can we invest in agriculture while
we are abroad
this is one question which have been
asked with different people
and a lot of people who are living
abroad mostly
diasporas so i decided in order to catch
up with them in order to help them
i should say my comment on this but this
also will be useful
not only to people who want to invest in
tanzania but
also for other people who are living in
other areas
and they want to do agriculture mostly
in east africa and africa
you can use just these few techniques
they might help you in one or different
way so
let us go together and enjoy
first thing you need to consider is not
just the matter of starting farming
but you must choose a kind of farming
that you are capable of
and you are interested in what do i mean
saying this
people they are just entering to farm
just because
they are just told that when you do
farming you might get rich in order to
be
a successful farmer you just not you
should not just drag
into farming just this way you must have
an
interest and capability to start that
kind of farming
that is very important thing because
success or failure
starts from that point
second thing you which you need to
consider you must have knowledge
on what you want to farm people
must start having questions oh dude oh
i'm still i'm fair
oh i'm not staying where i do farming
how can i
how how is it important to have
knowledge on what i want to farm
don't worry it's very important to know
on what you are doing for example
in order to to know every step of maize
and how you will get profit you must be
aware of
how maze is grown and whatever process
of growing maze it doesn't matter how
far you are
but you must also have a person
who is capable and who is knowledgeable
concerning on kind of farming that
you're doing even when you're not there
or you're not around he or she can stand
on his
duty so as to make sure everything is
going as planned
but it's very important for you to have
not only you should go to school but you
can nowadays
life is very simple you can google you
can go to youtube and whatever
and have some basics and knowledge on
what you want
to farming this will help this is
important in cost management
hope you got what i mean right another
important thing
is good fun management this starts from
the
person or expert you're using from the
equipment you're using
from the inputs you're using all of
these must be good
and must be done correctly so make sure
you invest much in good practice
because when the fan practice not good
you can just end up in getting losses
which are not necessary
for example when the farm is not clean
you can just
welcome some pests and diseases for
example when you don't put
all requirements for example seeds when
you're not practicing on time when you
not put
fertilizers on time when not cut wet on
time all of these will be
problems so you must have a good farming
practice
starting from the good expert you are
using so as to take care of your firm
last but not least you must plan your
market you must
know how you deliver your products to
the customer
you must know who you are your target
customers you must know how you will
do your business how you sell your
products
and much more because when you're not
planning you might
just you obtain a lot of years but you
don't know where to sell them
so you just end in selling them by
losses or buy cheap prices
or many of the products might be rotten
so
in order to be a successful farmer you
must do off of this but
also be good in planning your market
be good to know where you sell your
products and whatever
for today let's just end up hope you
have just obtained something
or you've got something might which
might help you
and until next time this is baba tv and
this is bye bye man considering
subscribing
and hit the bell so as to be the member
of this
family till next time and have a nice
day